the fighter has boxing but it's not
about boxing it's about much more than
that the fighter so the fighters the
true story of welterweight boxer Micky
Ward played by marky-mark who has a lot
of heart but he's just been dealt a
really [ __ ] deck of cards in life he's a
fighter who's pretty much oblivious to
the fact that his lot in boxing is to
lose to other fighters to make them look
good he gives it his all but he just
gets pummeled and he hero worships his
cracked out washed-up brother played by
Christian Bale we'll get back to bale in
a second and he lives to make his family
happy the family that is doing nothing
in his life but holding him back
alright the family imagine the mom and
Million Dollar Baby had about ten kids
with Helene McCready from Gone Baby Gone
and they all lived in one house with
Mark Wahlberg and cracked-out Christian
Bale that is Micky Ward's life exactly
that type of family that actively works
to hold him back so they're all on the
same level of [ __ ] don't turn your back
on family mother knows best now gonna do
that mom I'm not gonna do that to you I
did do oh my god I literally wanted to
slap his entire family you hate them I'm
sure he loves them they're his family
you do not and his brother played by
Christian Bale alright I've heard some
people say that Christian Bale sucks at
acting because when he's Batman he talks
like this we're gonna bring Gotham back
say what you want about Bale he out
acted everybody in this movie everyone
in this movie was good and he trumped
them all the story of Micky Ward was
really interesting but in terms of
single performance Christian Bale
absolutely stole the show he deserves an
Oscar for this guaranteed the guy's
absolutely dedicated to his roles I mean
he's thick he's stayin he's thick he's
like Oprah in the 90 students weight
just fluctuates there were times in this
movie I actually thought he was on crack
in fact I'm not totally convinced that
he wasn't he is either one of the best
actors out there or the guy was just on
crack and of course he is another
element in Micky Ward's life that's just
holding him back and Amy Adams she was
great in the movie too I mean she's
assertive she motivates him she is
absolutely everything that Mark
Wahlberg's family is not safe to say she
does not get along with the fan but then
soon after meeting her Micky Ward gets
this confidence in life and it's just
awesome to watch and that there's what
the movies about it's not about
seeing or going for a title it's about
becoming your own man is the formula and
the movie familiar yeah sure but it's
the guy's life what do you want the
familiarity of the boxing formula in the
movie is absolutely trumped by the
emotion and characters if this movie
just doesn't get to you you don't have a
pulse go see The Wizard of Oz get a
heart I don't mean the movie I mean the
actual guy go to Oz and get a heart and
a soul Marky Mark was good in this movie
he still shouldn't be Nathan Drake but
he was good in this movie Christian Bale
though I'm telling you Oscar
absolutely the fighter is definitely a
contender for Best Picture this year and
it is absolutely awesome tacular I mean
I was still emotional 30 minutes after
the movie was over that [ __ ] doesn't
happen with me I almost cried I'll admit
it chicks dig that right it's gonna stay
with me for a while it was really good
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]